[Music]
battlefield one wastes little time and
effectively conveying to savagery World
War one the Nevitt ability of death is
the focus of the bleak story prologue a
burning man screams can be heard at the
start of every multiplayer match in the
Argonne forest its ruination on a
continental scale a conflict so large
that it's location menus showcase a
large portion of the planet Earth ei die
splendidly interprets the early 20th
century as a world and technological
transition while humanizing as
participants through well-crafted I'll
be at fictional narrative vignettes
combined with an enthralling multiplayer
mode the overall result is the studio's
best work since Battlefield Bad Company
2
the horrors and heroism of the Great War
unfolds superbly in war stories
battlefield ones campaign it's a more
refined experience when compared to
prior battlefield story modes of
globe-trotting and OneNote powder-keg
narratives not only are you exposed to a
variety of perspectives from the
characters you play but also from a wide
spectrum aute evasions from
altruistically noble to self-serving wow
these are incredible yes it was a an
incredible time he looked very handsome
in that uniform that's not me that's
what they were
oh of course I'm sorry dad take as long
as you need
no no he's okay too Zoda it's time I
told you what happened to him beyond
these heartfelt tales of Brotherhood's
and solemn reflection war stories
positively complements the multiplayer
as a glorified yet effective training
mode along with practice time with
vehicles and heavy artillery those new
to the series will have ample time to
learn melee combat as well as surviving
against high concentrations of enemy
forces it also presents events that you
wouldn't find online such as gratifying
opportunities to slowly stalk enemies
for stealth kills or carrying wounded to
safe zones
battlefield ones multiplayer stays
faithful to the series routes of open
space combat now marvelously tailored
with World War one's weapons vehicles
and terrain it's centerpiece operations
is amateur ation of rush with the added
territorial draw of conquest one side
pushes while the other holds them back
and conflicts that can last an hour it's
not an emotionally draining endurance
match the changes in environments as the
battle progresses keeps the fight fresh
the fact that these events played out a
hundred years ago allows these conflicts
be analyzed with hindsight and this new
addition to battlefield offers a
surprising amount of historical context
thanks to informative pre and post
matched voiceover one can only speculate
what an austro-hungarian victory would
have meant for the future of Europe it
is possible success could have United
the crumbling Empire allowing the
Hapsburgs to keep control of their
countries races and ethnicities for at
least a few months longer like a band of
brothers reuniting the reprise of
conquest domination rush and team
deathmatch delivers the goods for the
battlefield devoted as always there's a
thrill in adapting to changing
circumstances mid-battle this is
especially the case for team players
we're constantly trying to figure out
how to be the best contributor whether
that means protecting a capture point or
stopping an enemy charge by assaulting
them from an airship
lastly war pigeon which has the
hallmarks of a throwaway novelty mode
shares some fundamentals with
capture-the-flag
where the bird serves as the flag of
course a mode is only as good as the
maps they're based in and every locale
has their own sense of character
compared to the many near symmetrical
maps in battlefield hardline there's
more thoughtfulness in making these new
fields of operations feel natural and
more importantly inviting the series
best maps are those that encourage you
to play outside of your comfort zone to
spend time with classes you wouldn't
normally play regularly and to play
around with the available vehicles sure
every collection of maps has this
inevitable share of bottlenecks and
camping spots but the outstanding
expansiveness of the maps and the
abundance of multiple routes in a given
area offers myriad opportunities to
circumvent these issues
Paquita
this degree of experience customization
extends to the robust and satisfying
progression system growing a collection
of firearms is rewarding for veterans
while the antiquated simplicity of most
of the weapons make the conflicts
immensely accessible to newcomers its
meat and potatoes 20th century combat no
drones or heat-seeking bullets to
concern yourself with every meaningful
action is recognized or even dealing a
flesh wound
earns you experience points you'll keep
coming back for more even if it takes
ages to get to the top of the
scoreboards however accurate or
inaccurate battlefield one is the
immersive production values superbly
amplify sights and sounds that have
previously existed in other war shooters
only that they're more noticeable and
better executed this time around it's
about the distinct clatter of empty
shells dropping on the metal floor of a
tank and the delayed sound of an
exploding balloon you blew up no one
would blame you if you got sniped
because you are busy admiring the brush
metal on the specific part of a revolver
[Applause]
with battlefield 1 EA and dice have
proven the viability of world war 1 as a
time period worth visiting and
revisiting in first-person shooters it
brings into focus countries and
nationalities that do not exist today
while also shedding light on how the
outcomes of that war has shaped our
lives as World War two shooters proved
many years ago no game can truly capture
the entirety of a global conflict
battlefield 1 is one such sampling but a
feature-rich package nonetheless in both
as emotional stories and the strong
multiplayer we will stated we would look
death in the eye and we will fight
[Music]